después de cuatro años de estancamiento
las conversaciones para un acuerdo de
paz entre el gobierno colombiano y la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional eln están cada vez más cerca el
miércoles el jefe negociador del Ln
alias Pablo Beltrán se mostró a favor de
un cess el fuego bilateral para llenar
el camino
en este momento no estamos
en un plano ofensivo Por decirlo así más
en un plan defensivo Si usted mira
es una actitud positiva constructiva
desde la Habana Cuba donde reside desde
2018 cuando fueron interrumpidas las
negociaciones iniciadas en 2017 con el
entonces presidente Juan Manuel Santos
expresó su optimismo nosotros partimos
de un hecho hay que construir sobre lo
construido si nos funcionó hacer una
ronda de diálogo bajo el cese bilateral
Pues vale la pena repetir experiencia
porque falta positivo
declaraciones llegan después de que el
presidente de Venezuela Nicolás Maduro
aceptar el martes la propuesta del
gobierno colombiano de ser garante de
las negociaciones de paz una vez más
presidente Gustavo Petro y a Colombia le
decimos Venezuela acepta el carácter de
garantes de las negociaciones y de los
acuerdos de paz de Colombia con el Ln y
pondremos nuestra mejor voluntad en
nombre de Dios padre todopoderoso por la
paz total de Colombia Venezuela Podría
tener un papel crucial en los diálogos
la guerrilla tiene una gran presencia a
lo largo de la frontera como venezolana
Pero además Caracas acoge a varios
dirigentes y altos mandos del Ln en su
territorio si bien es el inicio para
lograr la paz total prometida por el
presidente Gustavo Petro en muchos
territorios de Colombia el conflicto
entre los grupos armados continúa
violentando y sembrando lazos obra entre
la población civil